[Applause]
be glorious Monday everyone and what a
great Monday it is for you me and
America because our audience is back you
heard them
take that Wuhan lab
feel very well and we're in a brand new
studio
yeah
although I did find uh one of Chris
Wallace's old toupees in my dressing
room
[Laughter]
held
but no more taping from the men's room
at Denny's though I'll leave those
cameras up just in case but check this
place out let's do a sweep around here
how beautiful is this huh yeah
they did a great job
an amazing job
I haven't uh I haven't been this excited
since Geraldo removed all his clothes to
get a booster shot on his left arm yeah
he couldn't just roll up his sleeve he's
the only person I know who takes his
shirt off while getting a pedicure
you should see what he did for his
colonoscopy or as he called it exploring
Al Capone's vault
[Laughter]
never let him forget it but tonight we
got great guests right Mike Rose here
tonight
talk about a guy who loves to roll up
his sleeves oh come on but he looks
great rolling up anything including a
dead body in an area rug
who hasn't been there and there's the
great John Taffer
he's been in more hairy Dives in Jacques
Cousteau and he's closed more dingy bars
than cat temp on St Patrick's Day we're
also happy to be back at work unlike a
group of Apple employees who claim it's
racist to force them to return to a
physical office
again wouldn't it just be easier at this
point if these babies listed the things
they don't think are racist but they
claim that in-person work would make
Apple's Workforce whiter more male
dominated and less diverse they're
called Apple together which is odd given
they prefer to remain apart the
employees wrote an open letter
condemning returning to work after their
CEO Tim Cook announced they would need
to work in the office one day a week
yeah one day a week what we call Biden
hours
and cook said they would ramp up from
one to three days a week yeah three by
mid-may three days can you imagine if
this keeps up by 2024 they'll have to
show up five days a week
this group is all about the oppressed
apparently except for the 12 year old
Chinese girl chained to her workbench
for 15 hours without a pee break
assembling iPhones of course you won't
hear Apple together saying they'll give
up their cushy jobs and turn them over
to the underprivileged but tonight's
monologue isn't about Apple it's about
feelings nothing more than feelings
we've become a culture that's decided
that feelings cannot be questioned so we
allow false concerns to muscle out real
concerns now they're no longer just
employees they're victims just think how
dehydrated they could get from all that
air conditioning so why is this
important well my guess did not get to
where they were in life based on
protecting one's feelings and unlike me
not because of their good looks
you know they make things work based on
harsh sobriety fact is every hard job
usually doesn't consider one's feelings
unless that feeling is your thumb being
sliced by a rotary blade and even then
I'd say put that Thumb in your pocket
and finish the job and then you can go
to the ER
[Laughter]
but in work that keeps
keeps it rumbling you shouldn't be
relying on feelings at all I don't want
to drive across a bridge whose architect
found out his wife was cheating so out
of anger he chooses balsa wood for the
support beams see the bridges they have
to stay up and for that you don't need
emotion you need engineering Engineers
are What Make the World Go Round they
made it possible for those Apple
employees to whine all day because
Engineers already did the heavy lifting
now it wouldn't be such a problem if
these emotive dopes stuck to occupations
that don't affect the rest of us like
being a producer at the Seth Meyer show
or the vice president
but the problem is they aren't they're
getting jobs at Apple which makes things
they get jobs at Disney which Grooms I
mean entertains kids
they get jobs everywhere and they bring
their idiocy with them it's not a big
deal if it's Netflix but if they're
supposed to make a sturdy Bridge that's
scary I mean we're at the point where
someone can argue that two plus two
isn't really four but it could in May
identify as five
and why can't a number be non-binary
just like my math teacher who only
shaved half her head imagine if other
occupations worked from home
Joe's Plumbing you Logan we unclog them
you gotta help me okay my toilet is
spreading water everywhere oh okay no
problem we can do this on Zoom uh just
hold your laptop over the bowl and
what's your toilet's password last word
it's a toilet oh it looks like what you
got there is a toilet spraying water uh
tell you what unplug it wait about five
minutes then plug it back in that'll be
500 bucks for the consultation I gotta
go Mike Rose online too
laughs
stupid broads
[Music]
celebrate work and the people who do it
they close their mouths roll up their
sleeves and they get the job done they
do the math so we don't have to
he's my favorite row after corn spare
and isometric host of how America works
on Fox Business Mike Rose
foreign
bars like I know getting thrown out of
them host a bar rescue on the Paramount
Network and author of the great new book
The Power of conflict John Tapper
she's like her checking account always
unbalanced Fox News contributor captive
and at his height all fruits is
low-hanging fruit my massive psychic in
the NWA World Television Champion Tyrus
uh ah welcome to the first night of this
John Greg just quickly we have Taffer
and micro on this is like the tire this
is like the guy's guy town of all guy
towns I like this guy town you know this
is a guy town tonight I think we have
something to celebrate it
God Town provide info yo family and pay
in bills then you grill a steak shop in
wood with your shirt off and
volunteering because it's important to
get back to your community with John
Mike Tyrus and Greg ultimate
[Applause]
so John welcome to guy town uh the power
of conflict okay this is in this book
goes against everything I just did in
the monologue no one like no one wants
to talk back or no one wants to engage
people for fear of being called names
how would you advise Tim Cook I think
Tim Cook should speak back yeah I mean
we have to say what we believe if we all
stop saying what we believe what we
believe disappears so how do we protect
what we believe if we don't speak up so
the purpose of the book was to give
people the tools they need to have the
confidence to speak up and stick up for
the things that are important to them
any good bars you've been to lately
unfortunately the past couple weeks have
been in production so now not as long as
I've ever seen ah geez well this gets
worse and worse Mike pain is real yeah
the pain is real Mike you know clearly
covet has changed the way we work but
one day in the office that is kind of a
hardship don't you agree it's going to
be fun to watch how this plays out
honestly I mean with respect to Tim and
a lot of other people in his position
you know they're they're the clouds from
which the snowflakes fell yes right and
so we're dealing in a weird way and I
say this with great respect but I read
everything that Apple together sent and
it it's a list of Demands right they
didn't pick up the phone and say Mr cook
we'd love to sit down with you and talk
about some ideas regarding work life
balance and so forth they listed demands
and so what's he gonna do yeah you know
when a kid throws a temper tantrum what
does the parent do do you negotiate with
a terrorist right what do you do with so
he's in a situation right now and it's I
have no I idea what his move is going to
be but I'm pretty sure that if the
employees are allowed to determine when
they work how much they work and what
they do
guys like Tim are going to think twice
before starting a business yeah I I
would I would not want to start a
business right now unless it's like
something really cool you know like
making dune buggies
practice buildings are in Prejudice
people are yes buildings are not
prejudices exactly I don't know why like
if the thing that kills me about this
Tyrus is that they actually have a
certain amount of privilege in that they
have a job that allows them not to have
to travel a plumber does not have
work-at-home privileges neither do I
yeah by the way you commute pretty far
yeah in a plane yes exactly exactly and
you never told me I could just come in
one day
although you did for a while yeah I did
boy that was a hell of a run
you know a couple things the word racist
keeps coming up right racist racist
they made a statement that if we brought
people into work
that it would become racist because all
the white guys would show up
I'm going to say that again
if it's so good we all have to come to
work the only ones who show up to work
are white guys yes
so
so I had do we have the definite because
they clearly don't know what a racist is
do we have the dictionary the definition
for racist yes does everyone see it
basically I can't have my glasses on but
I'm assuming it says something of the
effect when you don't like people who
don't look like you or think like you
right correct that's and not see the
wokes version of racism
[Laughter]
or the joke version of racism yeah I
read that statement so many times
because they said it was racist and I
kept waiting to see why and I was like
can I not read but they just didn't put
a reason why which I think they used to
at least make something up or say oh
it's racist because of this or that or
this history of this word used to be
used this way and this other they didn't
even try they just said it it's racist
it also benefits the neuronormative
remember that yeah what's that yeah yeah
neurotypical which like as someone who's
obviously not neurotypical I make it to
work every day that is true it's amazing
you get to work it really is how you do
it I think you're amazing harder on some
mornings than others mic race is a good
point and even in my book we talk
conflict is sitting down and engaging
with people exactly talking to them not
giving them ultimatum and not sitting
that's not the way to start a discussion
exactly but they've their parents did
their discussing for them the bulldozing
then they get in the real world and
someone asked him a question they're
like Mom yeah that's why no one says
anything but
do you know during a job review Once A
Guy where I work brought his parents yes
he did
that was in the 90s
I don't know what happened after that
you know what else you said that was
really smart
um
when you were talking about bridge
building and engineering and I get these
every so often somebody offers me an
honorary degree right you go to a
college and you say some words
yeah it's gone I mean everybody's
getting one and um you don't see
honorary degrees in electric that's true
true you don't see them in trade schools
you know what I want it's like honorary
I want to be an honorary doctor just to
give it a shot you know yeah it's kind
of like you know I'm not going to have
Dr Jill operate on me
and of course if she is a doctor she is
a doctor but she's not removing my
gallbladder
she's not going to show up to work
anyways because only white guys show up
yeah
I would Punch If I was at a black
panther rally and my brother stood up we
ain't going because only white people
show up to work he would be kicked out
yes he would hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else